I think pushing the little guy out its
kind of the wrong way to look at it I
understand why people would look at it
but its its scarcity mentality how many
people donating the wrong Kumar's knew
that Kickstarter existed how many more
people now know that Kickstarter because
of veronica mars the that audience i
don't think this idea of almost the
patron of indie whatever dance music
phone books that that donates to people
who likes to be part of projects who
likes to watch creative things happen
for very small amounts of money or
lesser amounts of money that it just
magically does stuff I don't think I
think its scarcity mentality i think
it's like oh that money is now taken
away from indie film neuro that money
was never added any film ever ever
Veronica Mars owned by Warner Brothers
comma down all it's doing is
bringing up all those fans got on it and
then all the people that some guy
donated 10 grand because it wants to be
on the show it's got a walkathon that's
a different game that's a networking and
again it goes back to how long is a
Veronica Mars audience built just like
Kevin Smith's audience it'll burn
they got to build an audience with the
old model with a giant factory that
caught up their stories now it regarding
Kevin Smith are doing much more indie
actual indie stuff then they haven't
recently passed but with Veronica Mars
it was never that audience bill because
it was a TV show it got canceled people
kept watching the repeats the owners
talked to a more or the director crater
walk talk to Warner Brothers and said we
can show interest will you jump on this
and they said yes and it worked in it
was it just became viral it was above
thing now is it going you know I think
the David Lynch and mark Ross can look
at the Twin Peaks audience it's been
building for almost 25 years and say hmm
I bet there's a lot of money out there
that would pay to see more of this story
I would I like similar story and i think
that's that's what the way i look at all
of this in people make Veronica Mars and
whatever however works would want two
brothers are all the rest of it I think
it's a firewalled situation it's a
one-off it's something that it will
happen again but it don't think it takes
away from the people because the people
who normally donate em kick sir did not
do any to Veronica Mars that's my guess
maybe I'm wrong but that's my guess but
that network was built it was huge so
when they showed up it's spiked it
spread quickly
when you're independent when you first
start you have a tiny little audience
you're only one person maybe it's you
cast harbors tweeting and on facebook
how many people can you reach it's like
there's a whole Dungeons and Dragons
world wondercon comic-con there's music
that none of us know about that the fans
are making a living they paid with
mortgage we don't know they exist and
therefore these huge fan bases that have
nothing to do with mainstream media
they've not going to radio if nothing to
do with any of that but they make music
they tour they do their stuff and that's
what this is there's room for all of us
we just need to stop thinking like
where's my million-dollar check where's
my the lotteries over kids the
Industrial Revolution ended now it's
time for us the storytellers to not
ourselves and to not get into this oh my
god Veronica Mars taking all our money
shut up just relax they're not it's not
just how many people do you know how
much money do you want to raise do you
think that all those people that you
know it can give you that much amount of
they knew that you get two million
dollars from their giant body
you